I spoke with Beth Schwartz and Marc
Guggenheim
this past Friday and then Greg Berlanti
this past Friday night and it was the
decision of WB and CW and Beth and Greg
and Mark in a very mutual way based off
of what they thought was best for the
show creatively and and being very
honorable and respectful as pertains to
to my wishes that we were gonna end
after a 10 episode run next year
and I miss that a great deal but
something tells me
even when I'm done I won't be gone if
you've watched the arrow verse you
should understand that thank you very
much guys they'll be more for me I'm
sure that I'll get a chance to talk more
about it but I wanted you to hear about
this for me I think I think it's been a
good run there's no supernatural but
it's been a good run all right thank you
I love you all I will propose and toasts
to appreciating what you have
however long you might have it
hey everybody is Charlie as you guys may
have seen Stephen Amell just confirmed
that arrow season 8 will be the final
season there'll be 10 episodes so I'll
explain what's going on why it's ending
and what's going to happen to all the
characters in present day and with the
future of the flash DC TV universe is
going to be remember this is the comic
book universe so there's no reason to
freak out that the show is ending
because the characters will live on he
makes a couple clear teasers in there
like he says if you know about the TV
shows and how they work you know what I
mean when I say that I might not be done
even though I'll be gone we'll do a new
round of the DC Universe giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite arrow
moment of all time on the video first
things first we just have to say what a
class act Stephen Amell has been these
last 10 or so years that he's been
working with the TV show we've only been
watching it up to season 7 right now but
they spent a lot more time than that
developing the show and working on
everything so at the end of everything
for him it will have been almost a
decade of his life way back when my
youtube channel was just getting started
he was one of the first celebrities that
actually reached out and said hey this
is really cool I like the videos that
you're making he was probably the best
encouragement that I could have gotten
from anyone since then he just continued
to be one of the coolest realest people
in Hollywood but on to the important
stuff just breaking this down top 5
style number 5 why is arrow ending so
Stephen explains in his video there in a
very candid way that he just feels like
they've told the story that they set out
to tell and they don't want to be one of
those shows that limps to the ending he
makes a supernatural joke like we had a
good run not quite as good as
supernatural but we had a good run it
doesn't have anything to do with the
ratings I'm sure they would continue
making arrow for 12 seasons if Stephen
wanted to stick around for that long but
he just says that he feels like it's
time for him to move on and do other
things so that means working on films
other potential TV shows in the future
I'm sure sometime early next year we'll
find out what his next projects are
going to be outside of the DC TV
universe pretty standard explainer for
why they're closing up shop no big
surprise there but number four what's
gonna happen to the other actors and
characters in present day though
probably as you would expect bounce
around the other TV shows so Stephen
Amell says when he made the decision to
officially you know say time to go like
maybe we should close this down in the
next
couple of seasons he hoped that the show
would continue to live on the DC
Universe and when he said that he means
obviously the other characters
continuing forward on the other TV shows
so which actors which characters would
go to which of the other shows starting
with OTA first so Diggle would probably
crossover with the flash because he's
already done that and probably with the
Batwoman TV show like they just did an
Argus crossover with Lyla because they
did king shark and garage so Diggle
would do stuff like that on the flash
arrow and Batwoman are both kind of like
crime drama TV shows Batwoman will be a
little bit darker just like arrows a
little bit darker so the character of
Diggle already works pretty well within
that type of genre Felicity would also
probably do the same thing she would go
on the flash just like she's crossed
over in previous seasons she could also
cross over to the Batwoman
TV show to do the exact same thing that
she does on arrow be the woman in the
chair for bat woman if they needed some
special help the other characters in the
future timeline like you have adult Mia
Smoak you have adult connor hawke and
william if they come back and guest star
it'll probably be on legends of tomorrow
just because the time travel is an easy
way to explain how you can pluck those
characters out of 2040 because right now
they are in the year 2040 which is way
further in the future and all the
regular TV shows that take place in
present day we'll just continue forward
with their next episodes like they
normally would so you can't really have
those future characters cross over onto
the flesh unless somebody as
time-traveling so we're just a little
easier to explain how they pop up on
legends of tomorrow because the legends
are bouncing around a bunch even though
I do have thoughts about how much
further that show is going to continue
because their ratings are also declining
so they might close up shop after season
5 as well then you have characters like
black siren and Black Canary and
present-day they would also probably
continue to crossover with a flash and
Batwoman now nobody has gone on Batwoman
because that show hasn't happened yet
but both of those characters actually
originated on the flash Black Canary
came from Central City even though
technically she's an arrow character in
black siren crossed over was zoomed
during flash season 2 so that's where
she came from
number 3 I know you're asking does this
mean that the Batwoman TV show is gonna
replace arrow in the DC TV weekly
schedule of episodes probably but not
right away not till the second half of
the season in 2020 after arrow has
completed its 10 episode run right now
we
know how many episodes of the Batwoman
TV show they're going to do they're only
filming the pilot they have not picked
it up the series yet we'll find out
about that in the next month or so
unless something goes terribly terribly
wrong odds are pretty good that they'll
pick it up and it'll get at least 13
episodes per season if not a full 2223
like the other TV shows number two
really big question of the hour does
this mean that Oliver Queen is going to
be the one who disappears during crisis
on Infinite Earths someone actually sent
me this picture thank you I don't know
where this came from but somebody
already mocked this up remember the
flash TV show in the Norah storyline
with reverse flash is dealing with this
whole problem of the future newspaper
because currently it's still flash
vanishes in crisis per the teaser during
last year's Elseworlds crossover Oliver
Queen made a bargain with the monitor
this is that clip so remember this is a
very big teaser I think this tells you
exactly what's going to happen I know
what happens to Marion car now you're
here in the faint hope I can alter it
well you just said you were God now I
don't think you're testing us to see if
we're strong enough
I think you're testing us to see if we
are good enough the universe is a
complex piece of machinery and balance
must be maintained one change requires
another
how would you propose I keep the balance
he says balance must be maintained what
do you offer in exchange so I think the
idea is there implying Oliver Queen
offers to sacrifice himself against the
anti-monitor or whoever the villain is
going to be for crisis on Infinite
Earths I really hope that it's gonna be
the anti-monitor but Stephen amell's
teaser in his little explainer video
about why he's ending arrow says that he
might be gone but not completely done in
the DC TV universe means exactly what
you think it means
so yes Oliver Queen probably vanishes in
crisis but in a post-credits scene they
do a Batman final crisis twist as a
callback to the very first episode of
arrow where Green Arrow washes up
somewhere mysterious on a beach or
something like that in a scene mirroring
the pilot episode so he's vanished
seemingly dead but technically not dead
which is also kind of paying reference
to the flash crisis on Infinite Earths
twist where he seemingly dies
sacrificing himself saving the entire
multiverse and later we find out via the
Geoff Johns rebirth run that he had just
disappeared into the Speed Force he'd
turned into pure energy if you never
read the Final Crisis storyline Batman
was seemingly killed by Darkseid's Omega
beams but what they really did is they
just sent him back in time so he was
time displaced working his way back to
present day number one though really big
question what does that mean they're
gonna do for the arrow series finale
episode which will be episode 10 the
very last one probably gonna air right
after the crisis on Infinite Earths
crossover episodes until they give us
some more detailed information the most
likely scenarios is the schedule for all
the DC TV shows next season the flash
arrow Supergirl legends of tomorrow is
the same as it was last year
the crossover episodes are episode 9 for
most of the TV shows that's their
mid-season finale typically so crisis on
Infinite Earths ends with a huge
cliffhanger multiverse shattering
consequences like psycho-pirate says
worlds will live worlds will die and the
DC TV universe will never be the same
Oliver Queen disappears as a result of
his sacrifice everybody's just left
wondering what's gonna happen next and
we have to wait till the second half of
the season on the flash and Supergirl
these other TV shows to find out how
they're going to carry the story forward
and address all those things but when
exception to that is that the week after
the crisis on Infinite Earths crossover
they
err the arrow 10th episode finale is a
sort of epilogue for crisis on Infinite
Earths 2 1 memorialize Oliver Queen they
have some sort of memorial service in a
dress what's happening in present day
with the characters going forward and
the characters in the future timeline if
you haven't been watching arrow quick
catch up there's a team in the future
that's slowly coming together they'll be
the new team arrow in Star City 2040
Connor Hawke will probably pick up the
mantle of Green Arrow officially Mia
Smoke Oliver Queen's daughter will
probably become Mia Dearden from the
comics William will probably become
their new man in the chair like Felicity
was in present day in Felicity will
become more of a Moira queen type power
player behind the scenes with a lot of
secrets and intrigue I feel like Kara
has had a good run I'm sure that they
have a really solid plan for how they're
going to end things in a really big love
letter to the fans through the character
in a way that will also let you know how
these characters will continue within
the universe so just post all your
reactions in the comments below
what'll happen is is there's more Shazam
footage that'll be posting real soon
I'll do a video for that my Captain
Marvel review and Easter eggs and all
that stuff leave your requests in the
comments below click here to rewatch the
Game of Thrones season 8 trailer a
billion more times and click here for
this week's king shark versus Grodd
flash Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]